I live here just right across the street
and the pigeons are a nuisance Richard
Evans is among many Toronto residents
that won't be taking any more crap from
pigeons they line up on this wire here
across Young Street hundreds of them
they have a habit of going to the
washroom on the streets and cars and
that sort of thing hello little one as
the rard of Toronto Animal Services has
heard many concerns similar to Evans a
city solution putting pigeons on the
Hill it's a food it's a bait it's like a
pelleted food um and we put it in an
automatic feeder and it sits on the roof
and it feeds for a certain number of
seconds that food acts as birth control
for pigeons at a cost of $24,000 a year
feeders were installed in four Wards in
May 2023 a Fifth Ward Spadina Fort York
will be added to the pilot project later
this month for an additional
$6,000 it only has this this
contraceptive and
effect in species that have feathers and
lay eggs so you know there's no risk to
your pets or small children the CEO of
the company behind the pill says it's
approved by Humane Societies in Canada
and that the size of the pill and the
location of feeders is designed to
attract only
pigeons I am advocating vigorously for
it to come to my w unfortunately due to
the pigeon population many residents no
longer are able to use their outdoor
space atart says the program has seen
some signs of success due to less
pigeons at the feeders but they're
hoping to have a better idea on how it's
controlling the population by this
spring or
summer ibraim Global
News